the island you once knew
has flipped
[Music]
welcome to chapter three where there are
brand new places to explore and exciting
new ways to experience fortnite like
never before
start by earning battle pass xp beyond
battle royale
it's all about playing your way to level
up and unlock battle pass outfits
including spider-man
there's also new features to check out
get around more quickly and invade enemy
fire with new sliding
and swinging
[Music]
and even set up camps where you and your
squad can heal and store items from
match to match
plus there are new weapons and items to
help win a victory royale and earn the
ultimate prestige the victory crown
keep winning and keep the crown
along with these features
the island is all new
explore sanctuary hidden home of the
seven
in spider-man's home turf the daily
bugle along with many more locations
and with the island's new weather
conditions
anything can happen
in addition to all new gameplay check
out the chapter 3 season 1 battle pass
that features spider-man the foundation
and more newcomers
so what are you waiting for drop into
chapter 3 and start exploring the new
island because you never know what you
might find
[Music]
you